OFF FOR THEIR 7th GAME
SLIM PICKING, THEY CANNOT SCORE
AND HAVEN'T BEEN DEFENDING WELLD
LEEP, GET THE FIRST
MAN STRONG ON THE STICK, NICELY
DONE BE TO GET IT UP
ICE.
HERE'S THE FEED FOR RADIM SIMEK
AN CHANCE AND
I LOVE TOMAS HERTL'S POSITION
UNDER CHIAROT AND IN FRONTLINE
OF THEL HANDLING IT GOES DOWN T
.
>> Drew: HECTIC IN FRONT OF ADIN
N
BURND RECOVE AGAIN TRYING
TO PROTOEK
AND THERE'S T TOUCH ANYBODY ON Y
IN
>> Randy: I THOUGHT ITITT, GOOD
FOR LOGAN M HIS BODY,
ALLOWS HIM TO GET HIS STICK Y M
TO HUNT HIM DOWN
NOW BURNS FOR LOGAN COURSECOND
ORR BALCERS.
--
>> Drew: QUICK, LITTTTNCE IN TH
GAME
CERTAINLY THE DIFFERENCE IN
KEEPING THE E OKED OVER AND SAWU
ZONE, CREATE THE OFFENSE OFF
TRANSITION, YOU WITHIN GOOD SAV
A WAY TO BEAT JAKE ALLEN WHO IS
HAVING A GEM AWAY FROM
KARLSSON AND BAC
WILLIAM EKLUND
LOOKS, SHOT, SAV SCORE, WILLIAM
EKLUND, RIGHT THERE AS THE PUC
PUCK LOOSE
RANDY,
PALACE IN 1992
ALLEN, ONE-TIMER, ON THE NET,
BALCERS IN AGAINST SAVARD NOW
TOFFOLI.
SHOT AT THE EMPTY NET IT'S GOOD.
JO OF PRESSURE
ON, HAVE SOM